thanks very much Kostas this is going to
be kind of an unusual talk for me and I
hope I hope you'll all agree that it's
in in the spirit of this conference a
little bit connected to the the open
directions topic we'll have have this
afternoon
and what what I hope what I what I hope
this talk can do is uh the way I'm in a
structure is going to spend the first
third of the talk going over a paper
that many of you in this audience have
seen but I would say most of you in this
audience have not which is my recent
work with Peter Crampton and John shimm
now in the quarterly Journal of
economics on the design of financial
exchanges and what that paper does is it
makes an economic case that the
financial exchange design that's
currently predominant around the world
the continuous limit order book has a an
economic flaw has a structural flaw and
that a lot of the negative aspects of
high-frequency trading are symptoms of
this underlying structural economic flaw
that part of the talk will be completely
standard I've given it a lot of times
many of you will have seen it I'm going
to give it a compressed and hopefully
quite accessible accessible form but the
remainder of the talk what I hope will
be the at least the second half in in
time is I'm going to talk about what I
see is some open questions and
directions for research on on the design
of financial exchanges that I think lie
at the intersection between economics
and computer science there's there's a
two page part of the qje paper towards
the back which I don't think too many
people read that makes a qualitative
argument no theorems no data that
discrete-time trading has important
computational benefits over the current
status quo market design in addition to
the economic benefits that are at the
core of the paper and I'll go over that
argument in some detail raise lots of
questions along the way
it's much less formal than I'm used to
so Oba the second and third parts of the
talk will be will be qualitative no
theorems no data but I hope that I hope
it raises questions and I think that's
in the spirit the spirit of this
conference is to raise open questions at
the intersection of economics and
computer science and to suggest some
fruitful directions for for future
inquiry and do what I hope is a small
bit of agenda setting so so the first
part of the talk will be completely
standard the second and third parts a
little riskier from my perspective but
your qualitative and I think quite quite
quite important ok so let me let me talk
about the economic case
the economic case for what are called
discrete-time trading or frequent
frequent batch auctions over the current
predominant financial exchange design
which is called the continuous limit
order book so the starting point is just
to tell you what the continuous limit
order book is just quickly show of hands
how many of you are familiar with this
market design about 1/3 how many of you
know what top trading cycles is just out
of curiosity
so continuous limit order books process
in excess of a trillion dollars of
economic activity per day that's well
known in the market design community the
basic building block of a limit order
book is a limit order it specifies a
price quantity in a direction buy or
sell for instance buy a hundred shares
of XYZ at $100 per share traders can
market participants can submit limit
orders at any moment in time during the
day and can also cancel or modify
outstanding limit orders at any time
during the day these messages sent to
the exchange so new warriors
cancellations that existing orders are
processed in continuous time serially in
order in order of receipt at the serial
process the set of orders outstanding at
any moment in time so offers to buy what
you're called bids offers to sell what
your call desks is sometimes known as
the limit order book and trade occurs
when they
for a new request to trade comes in that
crosses the limit order book so a new
request to buy that has a price that is
greater than or equal to some
outstanding offer to sell or a new
request to sell that has an ask price
that is less than or equal to some
outstanding offer to buy so that's the
that's the basics of a continuous
imported book it's a continuous time
serial process protocol limit orders are
the building block let me now give you
the the conceptual critique of
continuous time limit order books from
the from my paper with with Crampton and
scheme' I'm gonna give you a
stripped-down version of that papers
model which is already an extremely
stripped-down stripped-down model so
there's a security qualitex that trades
on a continuous limit order book market
there's a publicly observable signal
call it Y of the value of the security X
Y jumps around as a plus on a jump
process I'm going to make a purposely
strong assumption which is that X is
worth Y X is the value of X is perfectly
correlated to this public signal Y and
moreover X can always be cautiously
liquidated at this at this value Y these
two types of players in this model
investors in trading firms investors are
mechanical they arrive stochastic we
know market according to some Poisson
process randomly needing to either buy
or sell a unit of X and then there are
trading firms there are n trading firms
in the market and they're I'm gonna
assume that they're all equally fast
they all have actually zero zero latency
and this stylized stylized setup so a
trading if a trading firm decides at
some time T that it wants to submit an
order cancel an order that message
reaches the exchange at exactly that
time time T there's no latency so what
I'm trying to do at this model is to
create a if you will best-case scenario
for price discovery and liquidity
provision in this status quo market
design the continuous limit order book
I've assumed way asymmetric information
all participants know that X is worth Y
the zoom do I inventory costs X as
always
at value why investors are mechanical
there's no latency in the system it's a
best case a best case for this for this
market design so given this set up you
might conjecture that competition among
the trading firms leads to effectively
free liquidity for investors I've
stripped out all of the usual costs of
providing liquidity in a financial
market asymmetric information inventory
costs and so forth so what you might
expect is that if you're an investor you
can show up to market and buy X at Y the
trading firm should be willing to offer
X at Y that's not what's going to happen
in this market design due to a
phenomenon that we call call sniping so
suppose I'm making a market in X this is
my my bid my off I'm going to use my
hands a lot over the next few slides
this is my offer to buy my bed this is
my offer to sell my ask and I'm getting
signals from other markets called call
them wise this is the signal I and
suppose this signal I jump so from this
level to say up here so what am I going
to do as a trading firm engaged in
liquidity provision I'm going to send a
message to the limit order book saying
cancel these quotes this bid this ask
replace what these quotes this bid this
ask that reflect the new public signal
new public information why okay so
that's what a liquidity providing firm
will do when there's a change in the
public information can't soul replace
the exact same time that I say cancel
these quotes replace them with these
quotes 12 mas I'll pick on I'll pick on
you if that's okay is gonna send a
message to the exchange saying I want to
buy at this old s price and Custis is
also gonna send a message to the
exchange saying I want to buy at this
old s price in fact the whole room is
gonna say I want to buy at this old s
price so because the market is
processing these messages in continuous
time in a serial process it's a bit
random which one message reaches the
exchange first in fact if there are n of
us all equally fast it's a one out of n
chance that my request
soul is processed before one of your
requests to snipe me to trade at my old
ask price so I want you to take three
things and this is all worked out in
exquisite detail and in the academic
paper but I want to give you three free
takeaways from from this idea of sniping
sniping right now
so the first takeaway is that yeah
please yeah so why is publicly
observable so no it's a continuous-time
model so the then it's a continuous-time
model it's a plus on jump process so at
any moment in time there might be a jump
in which case why jumps from this level
to this level or this level to this
level the this sniping phenomenon which
I've talked about in the last few slides
the reason the prior literature mists
debt is is the prior literature had
modeled limit order books using
discrete-time sequential move of
abstractions which are really important
and crucial for identity for analyzing
certain kinds of economic phenomena but
miss the possibility that when there's a
news event all 50 of us react at the
same time to that news event and then
serial processing kicks in and it's kind
of random who gets processed processed
first so I want you to take three things
from this little example with my hands
so the first is that mechanical
arbitrage opportunities are built into
the market design you can make money
there are rents from symmetrically
observed public public information and
this really isn't supposed to happen in
an efficient market we're all used to
the idea that you can make money in
financial markets if you know something
the rest of the market genuinely does
not know if you have asymmetric
information but because of the market
design you can make money from symmetric
public information and that that's
really it's really not supposed to
happen so it's a arguable market failure
second the profits from these mechanical
arbitrage opportunities come at the
expense of liquidity provision
so when one of when Thomas's request to
snipe me is successful that's a a an
algorithmic trading firm engaged in
sniping earning rents at the expense of
an algorithmic trading firm engaged in
liquidity provision that's the liquidity
provision function losing money to the
sniping snipers so these mechanical
arbitrage opportunities the profits from
them come at the expense of liquidity
provision and if you make liquidity
provision more expensive in a
competitive market that costs that
expense gets passed on to investors
that's why investors can't
in this model costlessly by X at that Y
even though we all agree that X is worth
y yes let me show you some examples
empirical examples on the next few
slides that will I think practically
answer your question in the model Thomas
has just bought something that he he's
bought something at a price here that is
just cost us the liquid dateable at at
this value and I know it by the way the
same time Thomas learns that this asset
is costlessly liquid dateable up here I
learned that to Costas learns that to
the whole room learns this information
at the same time it's symmetric public
information but because of the market
design because of the continuous time
serial processing somebody nevertheless
gets a rent from it but I'll show you a
concrete practical example that all
think make it a bit more real and I
think maybe literally the next few
slides okay so this creates a cost of
liquidity provision that gets passed on
to investors and manifests and less
liquidity and thinner markets and then
third that this sniping phenomenon
creates a never ending speed race
because it's a my incentive to get
faster to get out of the way of Thomas
and it's in Thomas's incentive to get
faster to successfully snipe me so you
can imagine where each year we're
investing in speed getting faster and
faster and faster trying to trying to
win this race let me show you two so to
your question let me show you an
empirical example of one of these
mechanical arbitrage opportunities so
these are the two most heavily traded
instruments to track the S&P 500 index
in the US the e-mini futures contract
the trades in Chicago called ticker a
yes and the S&P 500 exchange-traded fund
the trades in New York ticker spui this
is a trading day as a busy day prices
are fluctuating a lot but the two these
two instruments are perfectly correlated
over the course of a trading day as
you'd expect they both track the S&P 500
index is a mechanical arbitrage
relationship between the two of them
this is an hour of data a minute of data
and then this is what the market looks
like when you use ooh min to
high-frequency this is 250 milliseconds
of the day and what you see is is
instruments that to the human eye look
like they're moving in perfect lockstep
as you'd expect given the asset pricing
relationship between the two of them at
high freq I enough frequency move in a
much choppier fashion so here's the
price in Chicago jumping the price in
New York doesn't react for quite a while
also so the answer to your question is
you can't you would be the the arbitrage
opportunity we need to buy New York's
cheap sell Chicago expensive and then
that would be a that's a that's a hedged
position your long sum S&P 500 in New
York short some S&P 500 in Chicago and
there are fancier and less fancy ways of
executing that trade but that's that's
the nature of of these kinds of
arbitrage opportunities and what we did
so we don't have to estimate anything
you can see it in in data I'm showing
you midpoint bid-ask midpoints how large
is the spread the spreads quarter index
point in Chicago and a tenth of an index
point in New York
yes this is a big gap yeah this is there
is a lot of I picked a big one for the
slide there's a lot of money to be made
at this moment buying sheep in New York
selling expensive in in Chicago and what
we did was we looked at all instances
like this one we're net of bid-ask
spread costs you could make money buying
cheap in one market selling expensive in
the other market and we counted their
frequency we kind of how long they
lasted so how long until the arbitrage
closed how profitable they were and I'll
show you some time series facts on that
over the next few slides so this slide
shows you that the duration of these
arbitrage opportunities came laid down
over the course of our data from 2005
they were lasted in excess of a tenth of
a second by 2011 they lasted less than a
hundredth of a second and this is a
fancy way of showing the same thing the
profitability of these arbitrage
opportunities was pretty flat over time
the frequency varied over time but the
frequency was driven almost entirely by
just asking how volatile was the market
the more volatile is the market the
choppier is the market the more
arbitrage opportunities there are and
this is my favorite way of summarizing
the empirical facts is the horizontal
axis here is time from a millisecond up
to 100 milliseconds the vertical axis is
correlation the correlation between
these two assets should be 1 or point 99
something based on their asset pricing
relationship what you see is that 100
milliseconds you see the correlation
getting higher and higher in each year
of our data that's information getting
from Chicago prices into New York prices
faster and faster each year and
vice-versa at high enough frequency
though in a millisecond the correlation
breaks down entirely so the analog is
and this is the duration of arbitrage
opportunities getting shorter and
shorter each year and this summarizes
that there's nothing in the market
design that can prevent the arbitrage
opportunities from occurring in the
first place yes
you know when these arbitrage
opportunities exist you know the gap
might be large but the volume that you
can execute an exploit is not arbitrary
let's say it's like the volume at the
bid or the volume at the ask percent so
in principle
you could do an accounting exercise
where you've computed let's say the
total market value to all participants
in this kind of arbitrage in a given
year do you have an estimate of what yes
in this one so we could do it in detail
for this one trade and it's on the order
of 75 million bucks a year and we think
that's an underestimate for a variety of
reasons but they can think of that as
the order of magnitude for this one
trade how you scale up this one trade to
the universe of all mechanical arbitrage
opportunities so you know here's here's
I mean these are the most liquid
instruments in the market right so these
might be even more at these so here's
Treasury markets high-frequency data
isn't available isn't researcher
available in Treasury markets here's a
list of other highly correlated pairs
that we put together kind of for fun
that's kind of but they're probably much
lower liquidity than spy and the minis
right yes but spies a big one I agree
you know whether the total market share
let's say is yeah I would I would be
comfortable betting on that although the
data that you'd want to to perform that
exercise isn't isn't that researcher
available when this the data I used for
this exercise is direct feed not to get
too deep into the weeds it's direct feed
data from the Chicago Mercantile
Exchange in the new york stock exchange
buying the data storing the data and
processing the data on the order of 200
grand it's not not trivial for academics
to do that the firms that have access to
it don't share it with academics I think
it'd be great for somebody to do a more
thorough accounting exercise but that's
not been doable by academics I mean let
me talk about now frequent batch options
I'm gonna go through this this quickly
so I can get to the computational part
of the paper so at a high level frequent
bachelor auctions are identical to
continue some in order books but for two
key design differences one x treated as
a discrete variable not a continuous
variable two orders are processed in
batch using an auction rather than
serially in order order of arrival a bit
more fully let's say the batch interval
is 100 milliseconds just to fit
ideas during the Bax interval traders
submit bids and asks that can be freely
modified cancelled withdrawn as before
if an order isn't executed at one
discrete time interval it carries
forward to the next discrete time
interval until either executed or
cancelled just like standard limit
orders at the end of you generally
exchange batches together outstanding
orders computes market level supply and
demand curve supply and demand either
intersector they don't if they don't if
they do intersect transactions occur it
at the market clearing price that's
uniform price auction priority is still
priced in time but with time treated as
discrete so if I've been in the or in
the order book for many hundreds of
milliseconds and you're new to the order
book in this 100 milliseconds I have
priority over you if we arrive in the
same interval we have the same priority
an information policy is analogous to
continuous markets as well what that
means here is trade by every message you
send it to the exchange it gets
economically processed by the exchange
and then disseminated publicly the
economic processing though occurs in
discrete time so information
dissemination is in discrete time as
well I just to go over a couple of cases
to make this a bit more a bit more more
clear and real so so one one important
case is in most most instruments in most
hundred millisecond periods nothing
really happens so what happens in a
frequent batch option if there's no
trade during an interval is there's a
supply curve here in red a demand curve
here in blue all orders just carry
forward to the next the next discrete
time interval and now obviously to
display liquidity limit order book
market the second cases there's a small
amount of trade so here's a investor
showing up and buying at the Esk that's
also analogous to the limit order book
market and the third in quite different
cases that there's a burst of activity
in the interval so say in this
particular hundred milliseconds there's
a news event and lots of algorithms are
responding this is the case where
continuous and discrete are quite
different in continuous markets this
bursts of activity is processed based on
speed competition who's first to trade
at the old price in the discrete market
this bursts of activities processed
using an auction there's
price competition and this helps
liquidity in two ways so one is as a
liquidity provider I have until the end
of the interval until the end of the
hundred milliseconds to change my quotes
to cancel these quotes replace them with
new quotes and prevent my stale quotes
from getting entered into the auction in
the first place and second liquidity
provisions protected by the auction
because if I don't change my quotes and
Thomas tries to buy for me and Costas
tries to buy from me and so does the
whole rest of the room you have
incentive to bid more than my ask price
to to win the trade in the auction so if
you work through the equilibrium
analysis and this is all done in detail
in the paper of course frequent bachelor
auctions and hands liquidity they stop a
by eliminating sniping they stop us
socially wasteful arms race the cost
does that invest yourself to wait a
nonzero amount of time to transact and
people can disagree on whether that's a
big cost or a little cost so let's say
that you're you're a millionth of a
second faster than me and that's a
relevant time scale by the way in modern
markets maybe you're ten millionths of a
second faster than me if there's a news
event that is in the part of the
interval where you are ten millionth of
a second advantage over me allows you to
act and but does not allow me to act
because I'm a little bit slower than you
then you may be able to cite me so the
the ratio to have in mind is Delta over
tau where Delta is the speed
differential and tau is the batch
interval in a continuous market if
you're a tiny bit faster than me you
always snipe me in the discrete market
at Delta over tau and then the auction
based competition means that if you're
ten microseconds faster than me but so
is tamas and so are twenty other guys
you now have to compete in an auction to
trade with me rather than competing on
speed to trade with me yes
like money markets adopted this and the
others didn't or even if all of them
adopted this are you imagine that all
the different markets are using the same
synchronized clock or that's an
important practical questions let me
give you a couple quick thoughts and we
can talk about it more at the end so so
one thing the first thing to note is
that in the current continuous market
law of one price is violated constantly
right because in a continuous time
market if the price changes on NASDAQ
the price isn't going to change it
exactly the same time on new york stock
exchange it's not detectable with human
eyes and it's not detectable with
researcher available data because
research or available data is and
finally time stamped enough so if if
this were done in a if frequent batch
auctions were adopted by multiple
exchanges at once you'd be able to
detect law of one price violations in a
way that you can't in the current market
design but that doesn't mean that it's
better or worse it just you'd be able to
detect it because the data would be
clearer a second thing to say is that if
a single exchange went to discrete while
others remained continuous that one
exchange that went discrete would be
eliminating latency arbitrage on its
exchange that's like eliminating a tax
on liquidity provision on its exchange
and an economic intuition is that if
there's two exchanges a and B and on B
there's a high tax of providing
liquidity on a there isn't overtime we
would expect aid to be able to win now
there are some frictions against a
winning there's a coordination challenge
of launching a new marketplace there's
regulatory ambiguities that the SEC
chairs talked about in the context of
this of this work and there's also
vested interests is that there's a lot
of money to be made by exchanges from
the status quo design where among other
things they sell colocation services
they sell proprietary data feeds they
sell microwave connections between
exchanges so I think it's an important
that's an important practical question
one we could we could talk about at
length later yes
I imagine you have an opinion on ie X's
proposal to instead just insert latency
into every order but to keep a
continuous time exchange yes let me tell
you how how IEX works and I'll give you
my kind of one-minute response on that
the way I X works is here's the market
the world changes ie X has this 350
millionth of a second speed bump so if
you if Thomas comes to try to trade with
me promise is delayed by 3 or 50
millionths of a second if I try to
remove my quotes and adjust them I'm
also delayed by 3 to 50 millionth of a
second but ie X sees that the world's
changed in two hundred millionth of a
second and automatically slides my
prices to reflect the new information so
I think that's quite ingenious the the
liability of that design is it requires
IX to know where to look for prices so
when you hear the i-x guys talk about
their market design they always say well
where do you get prices from on your
market and I always think well the way I
get where I get prices from our market
is from my market it's a market the
whole purpose is to discover prices but
if you think through the mechanics of
their market design it really relies on
being able to look elsewhere for for
price informations I think it's
ingenious I don't know what they'll do
right now they're one-and-a-half percent
I don't know if it works if they're 20%
if they're meaningfully contributing to
price discovery and not just looking to
prices elsewhere so I think they exist
that's better than I can say but I think
that's the weakness of their design
relative to mind yes it's not everything
the same amount at random delay so
random delay we have an equilibrium
analysis it leads to infinite message
traffic and does not address sniping so
random though there are many there are
many ideas that have been batted about
by folks with game theoretic intuitions
most of which are bad and I can analyze
them in the paper and I don't mean to
pick on you that but um but we write
it's good to throw spaghetti at the wall
right but know that that's when we can
analyze I think the thing I would
emphasize is that and this also relates
to the i-x question I think our paper
identifies continuous times
cereal processing as the root flaw it
creates rents from public information
the rents from public information harm
liquidity induce a speed race the
solution to that is to make time
discrete and batch process and there are
lots of other intuitions you could come
up with if you think the problem is an
arms race and let's just stop speed
competition but I think the route
problem is a flaw in the market design
and we directly address that so I've got
about 8 minutes I'm gonna go through
what I hope to spend most of my time on
but we that's fine I'm happy to get
sidetracked which is the computational
advantages of discrete time trading this
is the qualitative part of the paper
it's two pages towards the back and I
hope raises questions that I think a
combination of economic economists and
computer scientists could could find
fruitful to address so the cut the
context is that there have been a lot of
computational issues with modern
financial markets there have been flash
crashes that are have gotten a lot of
attention there's a flash crash in
equities in 2010 and Treasuries in 2014
there's many flash crashes and
individual stocks on a more regular
basis as a mini flash cash in Google
stock just for how variants benefit but
numerous exchange glitches there's but
we've been coding hers have gotten a lot
of attention would I make an argument
for in the paper towards the back is
that discrete time has computational
simplicity advantages relative to
continuous time and with specific
benefits we describe for exchanges
algorithmic traders and regulators and
and the rough the rough intuition is
that continuous time markets often
implicitly assume that there's no
latency and that computers are
infinitely fast and computers and
communications are very fast but not
infinitely fast and discrete time
respects respects limits in ways that
simplify simplify markets there's a
qualitative informal argument again
bring it up here I put it in the paper
in part to respond to the concern well
you're proposing a new market design
what about unintended consequences and
the unintended consequences folks often
reach for are these kinds of
computational
computational glitches dramatic
computational events and I wanted to say
in the paper well if anything I think
the computational case favor is discrete
time over continuous time continuous
time has had all of these negative
consequences for markets but it's
informal and qualitative so so I thought
it was useful to include in the paper
but but it's informal we go through the
computational benefits for exchanges so
in continuous time exchanges faced a
problem of backlog so processing any
single order is computationally trivial
disseminating a message is
computationally trivial trivial trivial
operations take nonzero time we don't
need to be a computer scientist to know
that an implication is that during when
there's a lot of activity exchanges
might get might get back lop and this is
a graph showing the backlog that the
Chicago Mercantile Exchange faced during
the Treasury market flash crash last
October and what this means is that
algorithms are left uncertain about the
state of their orders in the state of
the market precisely when there's a lot
of activity precisely during times of
duress discrete time batch auctions are
also computationally trivial later and
login and you can set the backs interval
to be long relative to realistic
worst-case processing time so I had an
RA use a laptop to figure out how long
it takes to run batch auctions at the
level of message activity during the
flash crash and you could clear batch
auctions at 10 milliseconds on an
ordinary laptop using C++ it's not you
could use a realistic batch interval and
have have a cushion relative to a
realistic worst-case processing time
like a research question is the economic
consequences of backlog on the one hand
60 milliseconds of backlog in a box
Black Swan events pretty good the other
hand its it occurs precisely during
during times of confusion and duress the
second a second computational benefit of
discrete time is it simplifies message
processing details for exchanges so if
there's a large trade that triggers a
lot of messages it triggers trade
updates to participants in the trade and
it triggers book updates to the market
as a whole saying that the
prices updated in continuous-time
exchanges have to make a decision about
the order in which to disseminate these
messages the Chicago Mercantile Exchange
as matching engine sent out the trade
updates before the book updates so savvy
high-frequency traders figured out well
if I put Sentinel orders in the book I
can get information that there's been a
large market move before it's publicly
disseminated that there's been a large
market move in discrete-time all of this
stuff goes away you couldn't disseminate
messages that have economically the same
time another computational benefit of
discrete-time I think is it with respect
to exchange glitches the three time
justic simplify as the programming
environment in various ways as an
example Nasdaq at least when I last
spoke to them threaded all all message
activity through a single core for the
purpose of time stamping so there was
the whole Nasdaq marketplace there was
one core that was in charge of of
supplying timestamps for the market to
figure out did this action in this stock
occur before or after this action in
this stock and this becomes unnecessary
once you treat time this time as a
discrete I think open research question
is well simplifying the computational
tasks of an exchange does that have any
connection to these more dramatic glitch
incidents okay let's now talk about some
computational benefits of discrete time
for algorithms the the basic contrast
between continuous and discrete is in
continuous time you get a piece of data
and you have an immediate trade-off
which is do I respond immediately or do
I think about that data so there's an
intrinsic trade-off between speed and
smarts and algorithms have to optimize
over the decision of how much to think
about a piece of data before before
responding and discrete time you get a
batch of data at time T make decisions
for time T plus 1 there's still a
trade-off between speed and smarts but
if the Batchelor novels 100 milliseconds
in a sense the first hundred
milliseconds of thinking are free they
don't have a cost in terms of time
priority now research questions that
come out of this and this is a quote we
give you the
there's a quote from a wonderful article
by Donald Mackenzie's and economic
sociologist at Edinboro he was talking
what he did interviews with with hft
programmers one of them was saying well
there are rules you need to follow to
write fast code one of which is you
never use an if-then statement that
slows you down too much and then here's
another great quote took 52 seconds to
realize I've made a mistake by the time
I press the red button we'd lost three
million dollars the computer that in
another twenty seconds the firm would
have been bankrupt in another 50 seconds
they're clearing firm would have been
bankrupt and then they went on to say
that the whole system would have blown
up in another couple minutes I don't
know if that's an exaggeration but but I
think the the questions you I think the
questions for research are why I think
this trade-off between speed and smarts
is quite interesting and seems quite
hard to model a second question is are
there negative externalities from this
speed smarts trade-off so if I make a
dumb decision I'll lose money does that
have negative consequences for the
market as a whole
this quote suggests the channel through
which it might little last question is
how is the accuracy of prices affected
by this speed smarts trade-off I think
that's kind of this that's a subtle
subtle hard question on the one hand in
a continuous time market firms get more
data that I frequency trading firms get
more data than they would in this
discrete time market that seems good for
forming a view on price on the other
hand they're incentivized to respond to
that data in a way that's fast as
opposed to smart that seems
counterproductive for the efficiency of
prices which is hard hard modeling
questions for the regulator
discrete-time leads leads to a cleaner
paper trail so in continuous-time you
have to adjust the paper trail for
relativity clock synchronization
mistakes it's non-trivial to figure out
did this action on this market happened
before after at the same time then this
action on that market in discrete time
that becomes trivial I think the
benefits of a clean paper trail is an
open open question my intuition is that
they could be large much in the same way
that we all have an intuition that a
website with good user interface can
have large you know good user devices
can have design can have a large benef
benefits for a website even if you could
form the same actions without the good
user interface but I think it's a hard
question to get get traction on another
computational benefit of discrete time
is symmetric dissemination of public
information in continuous time it's
technologically non-trivial to
impossible to disseminate information to
multiple parties at the same time this
is manifested in a couple of
high-profile controversies and even if
you could disseminate information at
exactly the same time the model shows
that economically that those messages
would be responses to that information
will be processed as if or disseminated
asymmetrically and discrete time all of
this goes away it becomes
technologically trivial to disseminate
information to multiple participants at
the same time so I think I'm out of time
let me just mention a few other
questions that I won't spend time on but
let me mention a few other questions for
future research so one is just flash
crashes I think it's an interesting
topic
you know the causes of flash crashes we
don't understand the economic
consequences of flash crashes we don't
understand and then the effect of market
design on the likelihood of flash
crashes I think we also don't don't
understand
circuit breakers is another interesting
topic for future research the idea of a
circuit breaker is well if there's an
extreme event let's take a pause before
resuming trading I think this raises
conceptual questions as well as design
details questions
so just to recap but the heart of the my
QJ paper is to make an economic case for
frequent batch auctions over continuous
time trading and eliminates rents from
public information Angeles liquidity and
stops a waste forms risks we also
towards the end of the paper have this
two-page computation a qualitative
section making a computational case for
frequent batch auctions the arguments
are informal they're included because of
the importance of the topic and to
respond to this concern about unintended
consequences I think they raise open
research questions and would naturally
benefit from a mix of econ and CS tools
and now I'll end with a plea which is
more generally there are a lot of open
questions about the design of financial
exchange
these are huge important markets and I
think there are a lot of questions that
would benefit from a market design
approach and toolkit and perspective
there's a fixed cost you have to pay to
do research in this area which is to
learn the relevant institutional details
but I would strongly encourage
especially young folks in this room and
young folks who people in this room know
to incur those fixed costs I think
there's a lot of a lot of important work
to be done now let me stop there I'm
happy to take questions or to take
questions at one point there were rules
that you have to order to old quotes at
least so many times before you get to
change them and and so forth so have you
thought about how that changes these
results at all yeah I have a bet so so
the taking a broad view of the last
couple decades of history we've we've
switched from human based trading to
electronic trading we've switched from
markets with designated market makers as
specialists for example to markets
mostly without designated market makers
we've also shifted from trading in
quarters of dollars to pennies in the
case of stocks and other markets have
gotten fired the the historical records
pretty clear that liquidity and markets
is better today than it was say 20 years
ago computers are smarter than humans at
aggregating and analyzing data and also
using price constraints has been our
obviously good for markets and ways that
have reduced the cost of liquidity I
think one thing we got wrong in that
transition from humans to computers kind
of relates to that question right if I'm
making markets and the good old days and
suddenly this whole room starts yelling
at me wanting to trade with me at my
current price I kind of have some
discretion well if you look at the rules
there's a little bit of discretion over
what to do in that in that circumstance
that suddenly all at the same time to
human perception the whole room starts
yelling at me to trade at a price so I
don't want to say that you could run a
batch auction that's
that there'll be a over interpretation
of the old rules but there was some
discretion there was some scope scope
for favor trading when we transitioned
from the specialist the human based
specialist market to an electronic limit
order book we coded up the limit order
book treating time as a continuous
variable serially processing all trade
requests we treated time priority as
infinitely fine and down to the down to
the nanosecond and I think that was we
kind of introduced this glitch so
overall the transition from the
designated market maker human era to the
computer era has been good for markets
but we introduced this glitch in the
transition and a lot of the negative
aspects of high-frequency trading I
think are consequences of this this
glitch saving the designated weak human
but there are market makers you do write
to nowadays so I was wondering you know
do they still have to take their quotes
even if everybody's yelling that they
want to buy from me I have to sell us at
a number before I jump in how does it
affect your sniping results so those
rules vary a lot by exchange by country
so so conceptually so designated market
having a designated market maker with
obligations to trade even in times of
duress is it's hard to do right because
doesn't in the in the 87 crash if you're
a designated market maker you just stop
picking up your phone because you don't
wanna make Marquez there's too much
uncertainty now if you're a designated
market maker you can you know widen your
quotes or flash crashes you can think of
as the non designated market makers the
equilibrium market makers in a market
without designated market makers
rationally decide not to offer liquidity
there's too much uncertainty at this
moment in times I think it's a hard
question I don't I don't think there's
any one one answer to your question I
think it raises a lot of interesting a
lot of interesting issues